we got this big story from wired.com
wired says why facebook why why facebook
instagram and whatsapp all went down
today the problem relates to something
called bgp routing and it took down
every part of facebook's business so
they say around 11 40 a.m eastern time
the domain name system records became
unreachable
uh facebook's outage appears to be
caused by dns however that's just a
symptom of the problem says troy mersch
chief research officer of cyber threat
intelligence company bad packets the
fundamental issue issue he says and
other experts agree is that facebook has
withdrawn the so-called border gateway
protocol route that contains the ip
addresses of its dns name servers if dns
is the internet's phone book bgp is its
navigation system it decides what route
data takes as it travels the information
superhighway
you can think of it like a game of
telephone
but instead of people playing it's
smaller networks letting each other know
how to reach them says angelique medina
director of product marketing at the
network monitoring firm cisco thousand
dies
they announce this route to their
neighbor and their neighbor will
propagate it out to their peers it's a
lot of jargon they say facebook has
fallen off the internet's map if you try
to ping those ips the packets end up in
a black hole so why did this happen well
let me show you one other story real
quick because this is where i think the
story actually becomes bigger on the
same day at 4 27 p.m newsweek reports
1.5 billion facebook users personal
information posted for sale after hack
could these be related i don't know
it seems like the dns thing might have
been an inside job
well whatever the official story is i
don't believe it and i don't think we
should uh because we're getting all the
information from i mean we got the new
york times reporting that this was
unlikely a hack we have rt saying that
on hacker forums there were discussions
about this but we're still waiting for a
lot of this to still settle because it
still just broke it was six hours 15
minutes and uh we're getting reports
from bloomberg that mark zuckerberg lost
seven billion dollars and actually went
down on the list of world's richest
people significantly because of this all
of course as there's a major facebook
whistleblower and major mainstream media
stories attacking them for not censoring
enough information i think uh even
though i don't have any uh evidence for
this i think that there might be
something else up here
that's bigger that could be a sign or a
signal against facebook to step in line
that's my just personal opinion and i
don't have any evidence to
is it kind of sad that mark zuckerberg
losing seven billion dollars doesn't
matter to him probably
why would it well it is kind of like a
slippery slope kind of thing though
because if this happens for seven days
straight
people are gone facebook's over that
would be awesome
yeah that would be really good
i mean
last year when i was on the show i kept
talking about the destruction of mental
health especially with big tech social
media and even though this facebook
whistleblower is calling for uh big
government to intervene she does
highlight a big problem and that's the
mental health crisis that is created by
big tech social media that knowingly is
hurting people knowingly is creating
algorithms that promote self-harm
suicide depression we look at our mental
health as a country it has gone down
dramatically and it will continue to go
down and it started to go down
dramatically
during the the major usage of social
media so there's something to really
talk about here we need a discussion and
and i think the discussion should be led
by is our life better without big tech
social media
yes and that's coming from people that
do this for a living so we genuinely
care about this
youtube's a little bit different from
facebook but still a lot of the similar
similar problems and so what they've
done is they've tried eliminating what
they view as fringe and therein lies the
problem
the the internet space got so big and so
wide so quickly that there was this huge
different like world of content and
opinions and personalities and then all
of a sudden the people that facebook
twitter youtube were like hey we gotta
we gotta reign this in because this is
getting crazy and then they decided
we're centrists we're good rational
people marx was right now let's ban
anybody who disagrees and that's when
they started going after like moderates
conservatives people who tweeted learn
to code yeah pretty much i had four
pages taken down by facebook and they
weren't even that controversial it was
just about asking questions and and a
lot of people probably that we know
about had their facebook page taken down
i think you had years affected as well
uh but we have to understand that you
know facebook is is a major company and
they have knowingly done psychological
experiments trying to manipulate
people's emotions through manipulating
their news feed so they've been doing
this years ago and i've been called a
conspiracy theorist like you're crazy
you're insane if you think that they can
make you depressed with your news i'm
like they were literally doing the test
with major universities out in the open
publicly bragging about it so to tell me
that they're standing uh idly by as we
have this record amount of self-harm and
again you could go on and and go on
different tangents i really want to talk
about how self-harm and depression leads
to more corporatism and more people
filling the empty void by buying useless
corporate crap and how this could be a
kind of bigger conspiracy here but i
don't want to go off on too much
attendance but i i think we all know
someone that has been very negatively
affected by social media either by being
censored or just being affected by what
is being uh thrown at them i just want
to pull up this fact check real quick
because you guys luke is completely
correct in the atlantic reports
everything we know about facebook secret
mood manipulation experiment they say
for one week in 2012 data scientists
skewed what almost 700 000 facebook
users saw when they logged into its
service some people were shown content
with a preponderance of happy and
positive words some were shown content
analyzed as sadder than average and when
the week was over these manipulated
users were more likely to post either
especially positive or negative words
themselves facebook knows they're
manipulating people they know how to do
it
but they were experimenting on people
without them even knowing that they were
being experimented on so this is the
level of data so let's just say there is
a hack if there is a hack all of your
private information facebook and bigtech
knows when you literally take a dump
they literally know
the the second that you have the most
intimate moments in your existence and
they exploit that for corporate benefit
there's people who don't know that
they're pregnant that are literally
getting pregnancy ads
because facebook knows that they're
pregnant before they are so this is the
level of information that they have on
you the data sets that they have on you
so let's just say hypothetically we
don't we haven't have confirmations we
have some reporting that there might be
some hacker leaks if if everyone's
private information about when they take
a dump when they have it comes out i
mean that's like some serious
information i wouldn't want people yes
yes but but hold hold on a minute i want
you to imagine the utopia of this future
right imagine so i'm wearing the smart
watch okay
and uh you know i'm looking at it and
what if all of a sudden it just chimed
and a little voice popped up and said
hello timothy it's time to poop and i
was like hey wait a minute it is it is i
did not know that
and then facebook was able to tell me
when i should go to the bathroom or like
facebook can track your cycle for you oh
everything we don't you dude didn't they
have that you don't even think
they had an experiment years ago where
people were in a
you know the whole holding space
whatever it was and they told them that
they had to wait a certain number of
time for the experiment but the
experiment was actually the fact that
they were waiting
and do you remember that is it there's a
bunch like that yeah yeah and it the
clock actually moved like two times
faster than it normally would
or something and do you remember this
and at one o'clock everyone it was
really like 11 but people were hungry
because they thought it was one o'clock
yeah yeah no it's a real thing i mean
brain manipulation the brain is is so
ridiculous ridiculously so so powerful
so hold on you know luke you're
mentioning that instagram and face uh
facebook make young women go insane
right you know about the stuff right um
i could tell you from a cultural
perspective from the dating field what's
going on in the dating world yeah just
culturally like my target audience is
young women right like young women and
lgbt people that are saying thank god
but the majority of people that have
mental health problems are young women
in general so i think social media is is
going to affect them more than anybody
else when you break down social media
too you got to kind of define it because
there's video chat where two people are
talking and it's being recorded that's
kind of cool then you have videos
where's one person talking that's a
little more psychotic then you have text
which is incredibly to think that you're
communicating with someone by reading
etchings on a wall that they put there
is to me is insanity
exactly so so here's an example i
tweeted i tweeted today people who claim
to oppose vaccine mandates but then get
vaccinated because they're scared of
losing their job and money aren't
actually opposing the mandates and
there's two ways you can interpret this
one is i'm saying they don't have
negative feelings towards the mandates
or the other is they are not actively
blocking it right so my point was if i
said i'm going to stop this bottle of
water from hitting the floor and then i
threw it on the floor i'm doing the
opposite of what i said i was going to
do i'm not actually trying to stop it
from hitting the floor but because it's
text this very short tweet the context
wasn't there and so half the people
think i'm i'm saying quite literally
that they don't actually dislike the
mandates right i posted um i retweeted
boyan slats ocean cleanup project
they're pulling trash out of the pacific
garbage patch and it was basically he
was like we're one sixty thousandth of
the way there we've almost got all the
trash kind of wink wink but for real one
sixty thousand the way they're seven
years off and someone just other people
were seeing it and the context to them
was we're doomed look at all that trash
we're doomed
boyle slot is actually a bilderberg
member i confronted him at
and did an interview with him uh on my
channel very fascinating young man uh
but but just to get to the larger topic
here you know our perceptions are shaped
by literal tech overlords that decide
how we feel and when you control how
someone could feel when you when you
control what information they see and
what they did was really dastardly
because they took raw independent
information they took journalists that
were actually doing good work censored
them first then they went after all the
little troubled some people and the
troubled some political personalities
but they went after political people
first that were part of the culture uh
so we have to make that clear over
people who hurt children uh we can't
even say that word here uh there was a
large number of people abusing that
platform in very specific horrible ways
but they went after culture and when we
look at people who are consuming the
news feed especially the violent content
that they see whether it's police
officers beating someone up or blm
beating someone up or antifa beating
someone up that has such a larger
psychological effect that we really
truly need to discuss this because the
ramifications are affected are felt here
and when you have sinister multinational
corporations especially facebook with
their connections with intelligence
agencies at the helm
plug in buttons saying we could control
and manipulate society this way or this
way and make them feel this way this way
that's god-like power and god-like
authority that needs to be put in
checked immediately i'm just sitting
here as like luke's doing this like huge
anti-facebook rant and ian's eyes are
getting wider and worse intense what's
happening
but but look look one of the important
things it's like we'll pull it back a
little bit
is that young women on instagram are
being fed this fake reality with filters
with just photoshop and then they're
trying they're like it's like an
escalation every day of trying to look
more and more like some kind of cartoon
character and because they can't they're
getting depressed there's a story i read
about this young girl who's like
she posted a photo on instagram
and then looked at her watch and tracked
how many likes she got in the first
minute and when she was down she deleted
it right away like oh no that was bad
what did i do oh geez i'm not getting
enough likes
that facebook knows they're driving this
into people's minds and making them go
insane thanks for checking out this clip
from the tim cast irl podcast if you
want to see the full show come back to
this channel youtube.com tim cast irl
monday through friday at 8pm where you
can leave comments and super chat and we
actually will read your comments on the
show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else go to timcast.com
become a member and we even have full
bonus episodes thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time
you